bonjour ravi de vous retrouver ici à
bruxelles au coeur du parlement européen
pour ce nouveau numéro dans un pub de
questions cette semaine est il encore
possible de produire en europe oui
certaines entreprises font ce pari nous
avons rencontré un chef d'entreprise
français qui a choisi le portugal pour
la fabrication de ces textiles il a
installé son usine près de porto il
emploie des salariés portugais le pays
attire les investisseurs pas seulement
pour son soleil mais aussi parce que le
fabriquer au portugal souvent
apparemment mieux que le made in china
reportage dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission mais d'abord l'actualité
européenne les attentats ont remis les
questions de sécurité au coeur de
l'agenda des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement mais au fait que fait
l'europe contre le terrorisme éléments
de réponse en images
une marche de plus contre le terrorisme
des chefs d'état qui défilent pour
défendre les valeurs du monde libre
contre la barbarie aujourd'hui à tunis
hier à paris copenhague bruxelles
l'europe attaqué sur son sol et à ses
frontières au coeur de ces valeurs
ils seraient près de 5000 djihadistes
européens à partir en syrie en irak ou
encore au yémen
radicalise et sur internet au point de
vouloir tuer leurs semblables beaucoup
sont mineurs partis un matin combattre à
2000 kilomètres de chez eux sans
perspective de retour pourquoi l'europe
manque de réponses face à la menace la
riposte tarder certains pays disposent
de services de renseignement performant
mais les échanges entre états membres
sont lents et toujours pas de fichier
européen anti terroriste un système
répertoriant tous les passagers
européens enregistrées sur des vols
internationaux un outil utile pour les
services de police mais le dossier est
bloqué au parlement européen certains
députés y voit une menace pour les
droits fondamentaux
les pays européens se réunissent discute
s'insurge condamne mais les actes ne
suivent pas alors l'europe est-elle
prête à agir contre le terrorisme
notre invité rachida dati bonjour je
merci d'être avec nous est députée
européenne depuis 2009 ancien garde des
sceaux membre de la commission justice
et libertés civiles au parlement
européen l'europe a été frappée
plusieurs fois sur son sol la menace est
très forte et on a l'impression que les
choses avancent très lentement est ce
que l'europe n'agit pas une fois de plus
trop tard et trop peu
il ya une urgence à agir et le parlement
européen après ses responsabilités les
états membres ont pris aussi leurs
responsabilités face à la barbarie qui
nous frappe et qui nous menace tous les
jours ce qu'aujourd'hui pour beaucoup
notamment concernant les djihadistes ou
terroristes aujourd'hui le sujet est
plus de savoir
vont-ils ou pas frappé l'europe le sujet
la question aujourd'hui est de savoir à
quel moment vont ils frappent et donc il
faut absolument mettre en oeuvre et
prendre toutes les mesures pour la
sécurité des citoyens européens alors
c'est vrai que je suis très mobilisés
sur ces questions au sein de la
commission que vous avez cités soit
qu'ils sont justice sur les questions de
sécurité et d'ailleurs j'ai été
nommé pour un rapport pour faire des
recommandations des propositions non
seulement quand tu pour lutter contre le
terrorisme mais aussi pour prévenir tous
les recrutements de jeunes citoyens
européens par les organisations
terroristes et aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que nous avons un premier outil que nous
souhaitons mettre en place qui font que
nous pourrions mettre en place dès
aujourd'hui dès demain mais qui est
bloquée effectivement au parlement
européen notamment par les
parlementaires par les députés
socialistes
et qui votent contre ce pnr européen ce
pnr pékin et 1 c'est quoi c'est d'avoir
une liste de passagers entre les quatre
connaître le tous les déplacements de
voyageurs au sein de l'union en peine
aussi à l'extérieur de l'union
européenne ça serait un outil efficace
que ça permettrait d'avoir de pouvoir
recenser et de retrouver les personnes
recherchent rechercher des personnes
surveillées ou des personnes signalées
de connaître évidemment leur mouvement
leurs déplacements mais aussi de savoir
comment ils financent par exemple leur
trajet est donc cet outil est important
et tout est aujourd'hui il est bloqué au
parlement européen ne notamment à cause
et les parlementaires libéraux mais
aussi en particulier par le maire
socialiste parce que je vous rappelle
que manuel valls a annoncé que ce pnr
européen donc c'est ce fichier de
passagers sur le déplacement de ses
passagers s'étaient c'est acquis mais
encore faut-il qu'il convainque sa
majorer les instances et c'est pas le
cas il était bloqué depuis 2013 là on
dit qui revient à l'ordre du jour paris
et parade est aujourd'hui bloqué à dire
les députés saucier et alors ça veut
dire que s'il ya experts qui s'applique
demain où c'est pour la saint glinglin
pour parler franchement il
faut avoir un double discours est
aujourd'hui la gauche a un double
discours alain un discours celui que je
soutiens qu'il me celui de bernard
cazeneuve qui effectivement très engagé
qui moufte en faveur de ce pnr européen
il ya celui de manuel valls qui disent
état qui s'est fait alors même que les
députés socialistes votre contre deux
buts et liste socialiste français votre
contre parlement en perte en gros ce
sera le cas il n'y a pas d'espoir que le
on ne peut pas il faut le voter qu'une
majorité au parlement européen donc il
faudra effectivement que les socialistes
soient cohérents pour qu'ils fassent
preuve de cohérence pour dans l'intérêt
de la sécurité de nos concitoyens
ensuite dans votre sujet celle de
discours en fête qui
met en jeu la sécurité nos compatriotes
il ya un autre aspect que vous avez
d'ailleurs évoqué dans votre reportage
c'est celui de la coordination et le
transfert d'informations fall échanges
d'informations entre les services de
renseignement et action aujourd'hui il
est assez incomplet et donc nous nous
poussons à ce que les services de
renseignement confère beaucoup plus et
beaucoup mieux au sein de l'union
européenne et puis le l'autre aspect
c'est qu'il y ait des contrôles
systématiques à aux frontières de
l'union européenne ont ri frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne
notamment pour les ressortissants
européens puisque aujourd'hui
l'essentiel fallait djihadistes ce sont
des citoyens européens donc il faudrait
que nous ayons un contrôle effectif et
systématiques à l'entrée de l'union
européenne
à l'entrée quand on passe les frontières
ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
alors dans votre rapport vous voulez
travailler sur la déradicalisation il ya
un pays qui a mis ça en place le
danemark est ce que pour vous il ya
d'autres pays européens qui ont mis en
place grâce à graver des
déradicalisation qu'est ce qui garantit
que ça peut réussir
ça fonctionne et au danemark aux
pays-bas il y en a d'ailleurs aussi en
belgique ont truqué il faut se donner
tous les moyens et il n'y a pas de
risque zéro de quoi aussi être conscient
de cela mais il faut se donner tous les
moyens pour empêcher nos jeunes d'être
enrôlé d'être radicaliser parce que
souvent certains pensent que c'est un
jeu vidéo d'ailleurs le premier lieu
avec les prisons de radicalisation c'est
internet internet c'est devenu le
premier camp d'entraînement virtuel et
moi je le demande et ça va être aussi
dans les propositions et je le ferai
clairement dans les propositions dans
notre rapport à ce que les géants du net
comme google ou les autres soient
responsabilisées y compris pénalement
pour vendre ce sale et responsable
aujourd'hui oui et prisa n'est pas un
tuyau ils ont une responsabilité vous
savez aujourd'hui on est dans la
responsabilité citoyenne civique on
appelle les entreprises ils font état de
deux rapports en démontrant leurs
responsables leur engagement citoyen
afin qu'ils fassent preuve d'un
engagement citoyen en interdisant
d'emblée les vidéos qui circulent sur le
net et donc moi je considère que s'ils
ne le font pas il faudra engager leur
responsabilité pénale mais lourdement
pénale alors quand on parle de
terrorisme la question du financement de
ce terrorisme se pose je dis clairement
ce que l'europe où nous pourrions faire
plein juste il est incertain pays qui
financent directement il dit d'abord il
faudrait qu'on met en place au niveau
européen ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui nous l'avons fait avec les
états unis c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
états unis peuvent avoir accès à toutes
les transactions financières et alors
ils peuvent détecter tous les
financements et glycines circoncis
traite ce type de renseignements si on a
besoin de connaître
un flux financiers concernant une
personne signalée au surveiller nous
sommes obligés de demander aux états
unis donc aujourd'hui ou en tous les cas
on n'a pas les outils légaux pour voir
le faire ne devra pas de base juridique
donc nous on demande à ce qu'il est je
le ferai aussi dans le rapport à ce
qu'il y ait des outils de détection et
de traque âge des financements illicites
des actions terroristes qui a des pays
auxquels vous pensez en particulier qui
serait derrière certaines alors sur les
pays où on a évoqué les pays du golfe
que ce soit le 14 saoudite le sujet
c'est qu'il ne finance pas directement
des actions terroristes mais il faudrait
un peu plus de transparence dans les
financements on d'associations et doigté
d'homos et qui a traqué faut que ça
passe mais il suffirait aujourd'hui de
vérifier c'est facile c'est une
information qui existent qu'on nous
pourrions exploiter de connaître quels
sont les financements des pays étrangers
sur notre territoire par exemple quels
sont les mosquées qui sont financés par
des pays étrangers
des associations qui bénéficient de
subventions ou de financement ça c'est
facile à avoir ce qu'il n'est pas
interdit de financer une association où
les mosquées c'est légal d'ailleurs vous
n'avez pas que des pays arabes vous avez
des pays aussi européens ou des pays
tiers à l'europe qui ne sont pas
forcément des pays arabes qui finance
des associations ou des lieux de culte
encore faut-il savoir
qui travaillent dans ces associations
qui gèrent ces associations est qui et
quel est le discours porté et par les
associations et par les mots ce qui est
sûr c'est que d'ailleurs comme moi j'ai
proposé à skier à l'instar de la
conférence des évêques qui nous ayons
une conférence des imams de l'ensemble
des imams pas uniquement ceux du cfcm
qui ne fonctionne pas pour des raisons
d'ordre ans présentation et de
représentativité mais que nous ayons une
conférence des imams qui soient claires
transparentes et ouvertes ça pourrait
aussi avoir mon pourrions avoir un accès
aussi une transparence sur les prêches
qui sont faits dans les mosquées par les
choses avancent lentement lentement
drogue là on l'a bien compris ici en
plus on est haut au parlement européen
il ya aussi d'autres acteurs notamment
la commission européenne donc on
n'entend pas beaucoup sur ce sujet ce
que vous le regrettez avec de toute
façon la commission européenne va être
obligée de suivre dès lors où les
professions sont sur la table moi j'ai
déploré
l'inaction de madame ashton et la
commission barroso moi je considère
cette saison elles ont échoué dans leur
mission
d'anticipation de prévention notamment
regarder sur les printemps arabes ils
n'ont pas anticipé mais quand tous ces
mouvements assez révolution en ce sens
ont été déclenchées à aucun moment là
étaient là étaient présentes ou n'a mis
en place des outils de suivi ou en tout
cas de l'accompagnement de ces pays on
voit le chaos qui existe à nos portes à
nos frontières c'est la libye c'est pas
si loin que cela ces rixes et c'est pas
si loin de ces mêmes forces de l'europe
et celle de l'europe et donc nous avons
failli faux sur la dernière commission
j'espère que cette commission ne va pas
faillir d'ailleurs moi je travaille
assez bien avec la haute représentante
aux affaires étrangères qui
effectivement en tout cas immobilisé et
volontaire des gens plus ouverts que oui
d'abord les ouvert y compris des avis
des parlementaires melki plus volontaire
maintenant il faut passer de la volonté
aux actes oui c'est le problème souvent
en europe eh bien merci rachida dati
d'avoir été notre invité place tout de
suite au reportage d' europe hebdo le
made in china semble ne plus avoir la
cote les consommateurs sont nombreux à
préférer les produits qui sont fabriqués
en europe les entreprises semblent
suivre la tendance nous avons rencontré
un français qui a choisi de rapatrier sa
production d'inde en europe au portugal
il a laissé l'asie pour installer son
usine à porto reportage de rim benameur
et ilana à zelko
eric sauvage s'est lancé dans un pari
fou faire renaître cette usine de
textile fermé il ya quelques années dans
la banlieue de porto
il travaille dans le textile depuis 20
ans sa société ne produisaient camps
nazis mais il y a deux ans changement de
stratégie le chef d'entreprise veut
aussi s'implanter en europe du sud
il construit donc cette usine baptisé
crescendo recrute 54 salariés tous
portugais un investissement de 3
millions d'euros une tendance de fond se
fait que nos clients qui recherchent le
manie de rock made in portugal made in
italy aussi pour avoir des produits
plus forts de leur ajouter de meilleure
qualité et travailler sur des circuits
beaucoup plus court donc répondre à la
mode ce qu'on appelle le fast fashion
avoir les bons produits au bon moment
dans les magasins c'est très important
et l'étiquette made in portugal roumanie
italie où
fait vendre aujourd'hui par rapport au
made in china made in bangladesh et une
image audio pour lui très péjorative et
ce changement de stratégie est payant
actuellement les prétendantes pour
pratiquement pareil pour la saison
jusqu'au mois de commandes maisons à
travers ce projet l'entrepreneur des
fonds aussi une démarche éthique qu'on
veut donner du travail dans un pays
européens frappés de plein fouet par la
crise beaucoup de l'ouvrière était au
chômage n'avait pas de travail donc nous
avons repris à peu près une cinquantaine
de personnes qui étaient sans emploi
parmi ses salariés emilia elle a
travaillé dans l'ancienne usine pendant
18 ans à sa fermeture elles se
retrouvent sans emploi
au début ça a été dur car j'étais au
chômage pendant un an tu n'as rien
trouvé
et crescendo m'a offert du travail et là
je suis rassuré sur l'avenir
hannah martin vient juste d'être recruté
elle aussi a connu le chômage pendant un
an après avoir envoyé des cv partout son
succès elle avait même envisagé de
quitter son pays natal
je me suis inscrite à des cours
d'allemand j'étais prête à partir à
l'étranger
et je me suis dit qu'ici je n'arriverai
pas à faire carrière et que je devrais
toujours dépendre de mes parents
mais par chance j'ai eu une opportunité
ici
comme la plupart des entreprises
françaises s'installant au portugal
crescendo a été aidé par la chambre de
commerce
l'une de ses représentantes géraldine
dussault bas vient rendre visite à un
entrepreneur gezin merci voilà s'était
concrétisé
plusieurs mois de patience le fait
d'avoir made in portugal
a permis d'ouvrir les portes dont avec
des entreprises qu'on n'aurait pas eu et
la valeur ajoutée du portugal et là
vraiment pas
principale raison de cet attrait pour le
portugal le coût du travail beaucoup
plus faibles qu'en france une heure de
travail coûte 11 euros 56 6 contre 35
dans l'hexagone et ce n'est pas le seul
avantage selon géraldine du soda le
contexte du portugal d'étape est stable
et étape est proche géographiquement
la main d'oeuvre parle bien les langues
étrangères
et puis la politique adoptée par
gouvernement en terme de fiscalité
puisque l'impôt sur les sociétés va
passer et passer à 20% et va passer en
2016 à 17% c'est que tous ces
avantages cumulés rang mais pays
vraiment très attractif une politique
pro entreprises pour relancer la
croissance la situation de l'emploi est
catastrophique au portugal
le taux de chômage atteint les 13 % et
plus de trois jeunes sur 10 sont
demandeurs d'emplois depuis le début de
la crise en 2008
cent vingt mille personnes quittent le
portugal chaque année
et nous revoici à bruxelles au parlement
européen deux invités nous ont rejoints
de député européen membre de la
commission de l'emploi et des affaires
sociales elisabeth morin-chartier
bonjour bonjour face à vous patrick le
hyaric
alors vous êtes tendre elisabeth
morin-chartier du parti populaire
européen quand vous voyez ce reportage
l'exemple de cet entrepreneur français
est ce que vous vous dites que c'est une
tendance de fond comme il le dit lui
même ou alors que c'est un pari fou
d'abord un ça me fait très plaisir parce
que je me souviens il y a quelques
années en commission emploi et affaires
sociales nous avons dû voter du fonds
d'ajustement à la mondialisation pour
réinsérer des salariés dans la filière
du textile justement qui avait été
complètement décapité par cette
compétition internationale deuxièmement
ça me fait plaisir ça me fait plaisir
parce qu'il ya un savoir faire humain il
ya un capital humain en europe qu'il
faut à nouveau pouvoir
déployer mais je regrette ce n'est pas
une tendance de fond oui aux etats unis
c'est une tendance de fond parce que
pratiquement aujourd'hui 20% de la
production américaine est une production
relocaliser mais ce n'est pas le cas en
europe alors patrick le hyaric vous les
membres vous êtes vice-président de la
gauche unitaire européenne qui regroupe
notamment les communistes comment vous
voyez cette réussite est ce que pour
vous c'est une exception qu est ce qu
est la clé de cette relocalisation en
europe ou non il peut il peut y avoir
dans certains endroits des
relocalisations mais il ya plusieurs
problèmes qui se posent si c'est si ce
sont des relocalisations qui se font au
détriment d'autres pays c'est un
problème d'autre part ce sont des
relocalisations qui se fondent dans le
cadre d'une de la concurrence des quand
vous voyez ce reportage pour vous c'est
le cas par quoi était atterré cet
entrepreneur devrait vraisemblablement
ce qu'il dit est vrai c'est à dire le
made in portugal je pense que c'est un
à côté de la production bangladesh où ça
pose quand même beaucoup de problèmes
éthiques de problèmes sociaux une
surexploitation le des femmes d'un autre
côté les femmes du bangladesh ont besoin
du travail qu'elles font donc la
question universelle général qui nous
est posée est ce que tous les êtres sur
cette terre dans le monde ont le droit à
un travail en droit de créer un emploi
donc on ne peut pas vivre dans un monde
de concurrence perpétuel où les
entreprises se délocalisent au gré des
opportunités qui se posent vous partagez
ces inquiétudes la recontre ce que je
vois moi dans ce deuil ce reportage est
ce qui me frappe c'est que ce nouveau
directeur de cette entreprise
relocaliser correspond vraiment une
tendance de la mode je comprends que
patrick le hyaric oui ne l' approche
peut-être pas tout à fait comme moi mais
aujourd'hui dans toute l'industrie de la
mode au niveau européen on a besoin
d'une très forte réactivité d'une très
forte créativité et donc avoir une
relocalisation en europe permet une
réponse rapide à une mode qui évolue
très vite et mais patrick le hyaric
parler aussi du problème de la
concurrence qui s'installe du coup entre
certains pays et d'autres au sein même
de l'europe et notamment les pays du sud
qui pratiquent
contre les autres mais pour ça nous
travaillons ensemble je dois le dire à
l'harmonisation
fiscale vous avez bien vu l'isie dans le
reportage que la taxation des
entreprises taxation des salaires est
une est un levier extrêmement important
cette harmonisation elle est attendue
semaine dernière nous avons
particulièrement travaillé sur
l'harmonisation des salaires et le
salaire minimum des chauffeurs routiers
c'est le même problème évitons et
évitons cette concurrence entre
entreprises au niveau européen et la
concurrence entre les entreprises c'est
finalement la concurrence du travail la
concurrence des salariés alors oui et il
n'y a pas de progrès en ce sens en tout
cas pas pour l'instant ni en matière
d'harmonisation fiscale
encore moins sur le marché du travail qu
est-ce qu on a espoir que les choses
avancent bas ici la question de que sauf
que soulève madame morin chartier juste
c'est-à-dire la concurrence fiscale est
un vrai problème mais on ne réglera pas
pour le bien des économies et le bien
des services publics on ne réglera pas
par une harmonisation vers le bas donc
il faut trouver un système
d'harmonisation vers le haut de la
fiscalité des entreprises 2 des salaires
en général et des niveaux de protection
sociale ça ne peut pas se faire vers
l'autre parce que cette europe ne
tiendra pas en entonnant vers le bas
d'autre part on parle de relocalisation
mais il faut imaginer aussi de nouvelles
industries demain de nouveaux services
la transition numérique la transition
environnementale et donc il faut un
projet de redéploiement et de re
développement industriel créateur
d'emplois stables et convenablement
rémunéré dans toute l'europe est ce que
ça pourrait rentrer par exemple dans le
cas du plan ou juncker qui a été annoncé
300 milliards d'euros d'investissement
pour relancer l'emploi la croissance en
ambiance on attend toujours les
résultats de ses 300 milliards forcément
il faut qu'il y ait de l'investissement
à des productions nouvelles selon comme
le fameux nous y voilà comme le dit
patrick le hyaric
parce qu'il faut bien se rendre compte
que dans ceux dans ce contexte général
de mondialisation l'europe est aussi
victime de relocalisation parce que les
américains qui ont des grands groupes en
france par exemple dans dans cette
grande vague de relocalisation vers les
états unis prive l'europe d'un certain
nombre d'emplois et on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui
il y a vingt emplois délocalisés pour un
emploi re localisées au niveau européen
donc vous voyez on les mots n'ont pas le
même poids en terme d'emploi et ça c'est
extrêmement important on voit bien que
il nous faut booster
la création d'emplois en europe booster
la création d'emplois c'est reprendre
l'innovation reprendre des
investissements massifs et faire
l'harmonisation fiscale et sociale pour
éviter qu'il y ait cette concurrence
interne alors là on avait donné
l'exemple du textile est aussi un autre
secteur qui se portaient pas forcément
bien qui a l'air de reprendre un peu où
ça va un peu mieux c'est l'activité dans
le secteur automobile
alors est-ce que sur ce front là non
vous n'êtes pas optimiste il ya des
mouvements qui se passe est manquée les
asturies la mouvement mais la
concurrence interne dans l'union
européenne continue de jouer l'industrie
automobile française par exemple et si
aujourd'hui un peu d'espoir dans cette
école il peut y avoir de l'espoir je ne
dis pas là il ya eu deux ou trois
annonces intéressantes les temps
derniers mais ça se fait trop pour moi
au détriment des salaires et au
détriment du travail or dans les dents
les facteurs de deux gains dans les
facteurs de compétitivité comme disent
certains aujourd'hui il faudrait prendre
autre chose que le travail par exemple
le coût de l'énergie le coût du
transport la variation de la valeur de
la monnaie ont des conséquences
considérables bien plus que
l'abaissement du coût du travail qu'on
veut nous imposer mieux vaudrait mieux
payer le travail et abaisser le coût de
l'énergie des transports et d'autres
frais de port et la priorité car de
l'automobile moi je trouve que un grand
groupe comme psa par exemple qui va à la
conquête de la chine avec un nouveau
produit la 308 qui qui marche très très
bien en chine où bien des produits comme
la ds qui fait aussi un tabac en chine
bon
aller à la conquête de nouveaux marchés
formidable pour nos entreprises et pour
nos groupes français et peut-être qu'ils
ne sont pas allées assez à la conquête
de ces nouveaux marchés au niveau
mondial n'empêche que moi dans le neuro
circonscription j'ai à rennes des
suppressions d'emplois dans la même
filière je dois aller et aider ce groupe
sur la filière française de l'industrie
tels que telle qu'elle est donc oui
conquête de nouveaux marchés mais en
même temps préservant le marlin au
niveau national semble que le contexte
soit en train de changer avec notamment
la politique de la banque centrale
européenne qui injecte massivement des
liquidités des liquidités pour faire
repartir l'emploi est ce que pour vous
enfin l'emploi se devient redeviendra
une priorité en europe et soigner de sa
politique ça du tout si les mille
milliards de la banque centrale
européenne d'abord si elle était
contrôlée par les par le par les
parlements nationaux les gouvernements
c'est pas le cas pour nom parce que le
c'est plutôt rigide c'est à dire la
banque centrale prête à des banques
privées à des taux nuls pour racheter de
la dette des états mais on pourrait
imaginer un autre système on pourrait
imaginer peut-être à partir du fond
d'ailleurs de monsieur juncker
on pourrait imaginer un fonds de
développement humain social qui
rachèterait de la dette voire et ç'avait
été un petit peu discuté un moment qui
peut la banque centrale pourrait prêter
directement à des petites et moyennes
entreprises voire à des groupes qui ont
des projets d'investissement de 200 les
dents traité de ne permettre à ces
facilités
les traiter un article du traité
permettrait à la banque centrale si on
en avait la volonté par exemple en
france de prêter à la banque publique
d'investissement pour faire une relance
industrielle une relance de serre
certainement mais moi quand je vois
comment il a fallu que nous nous
battions que je me batte personnellement
pour sauver le fonds social européen que
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
voulait intégrer dans les fonds de
cohésion
je ne suis pas très optimiste parce que
fonds social européen c'est le fonds
d'intégration professionnelle et vouloir
le mettre dans les fonds de cohésion ça
veut dire qu'on fait une croix sur le
capital humain moi je suis pas pour
faire une croix sur le capital humain
certes il faut certainement des nouveaux
systèmes pour stimuler l'investissement
mais il faut aussi préserver l'aide à la
tête bien il ne se sevrer lugnorre c'est
beaucoup souffert beaucoup de choses
merci ce sera donc le mot de la fin
merci à vous d'avoir participé à ce
débat sur un sujet qui vous qui vous
concerne et donc il sera à faire
évidemment maintenant de volonté
politique des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement d'agir ou pas sur le front
de l'emploi merci à tous et la fin de
cette émission rendez vous la semaine
prochaine même lieu même heure avec nora
ahmadi ciao
ouais